Halloween is just around the corner and memento
mori’s are everywhere.
Little reminders of death, Skeletons, ghosts,
literally show up at on your doorstep.
but if death really did show up at your door,
would know what it smelled like?
Hey guys Julia here for DNews.
Weird question I know, but we’ve all heard
the horror story of some one’s apartment
building starts smelling weird.
And for like a week everyone just complains
as the smell gets worse and worse.
Until one day the landlord checks it out and
finds out that the neighbor down the hall
has been dead for days.
ugh creeepy.
But the thing is, as….
common as the smell is, it’s hard to pin
down.
I mean scientists are very good at figure
out the physics of other senses.
Like light and sound.
But the thing is, scents don’t come in waves.
It comes in molecules that diffuse through
the air to reach your nose.
How they move is totally random.
The molecules bounce off each other till they
fill a space.
Once they reach your head, those molecules
fit certain receptors and trigger a specific
smell.
So maybe we have specific receptors to smell
death.
In the case of death, when something dies,
or meat rots, certain chemicals are produced
when protein decomposes.
It’s broken down into it’s smaller molecules,
amino acids lysine and ornithine, then, those
break down further into putrescine and cadaverine.
When those molecules reach our nose, we react
with revolusion.
But we’re not the only ones, surprise surprise.
Lots of animals seem to have an adverse reaction
to a whiff of death.
The zebrafish are a prime example of this.
In one study published in the Proceeds of
the National Academy of Sciences, researchers
sought to find what goes on in their fishy
brains when they catch a whiff of of death.
They found the fish react very strongly to
low concentrations of cadaverine.
The fish instantly swam away from just a drop
of death.
The researchers found that a certain receptor
in their brains, TAAR13c, fit exactly the
compound for cadaverine.
It’s kind of like a lock and key system,
the receptor only binds to that compound.
While that particular receptor is only in
bony fishes, we have similar receptors in
our brains.
And for good reason, Putrescine and cadaverine
warn us when something is wrong.
Whether meat that has gone bad that could
potentially poison us or when something dead
is nearby signalling danger.
We probably evolved these specific receptors
to help keep us alive.
For some reason, humans smell different when
we decompose.
Those who’ve smelled it say it smells like
nothing else.
Trace unfortunately enough, experienced the
unpleasantness first hand.
He described it as ““sort of like wet
dog but worse, wet dog but warmer and more
heady, earthy”.
A recent study published in the journal PLOS
one measured the smell of death.
Specifically the smell of human death.
Belgian researchers isolated specific compounds
from decomposing human remains.
They put pig, mouse, mole, rabbit, turtle,
frog, and bird remains in separate jars and
let them decompose over the course of 6 months.
Not the greatest postdoc job in the world,
but someone’s gotta do it.
The researchers periodically took samples
of the gases and found 452 organic compounds.
Only eight compounds distinguished pig and
human remains from those of other animals.
Which makes sense they’d look for ones exclusive
to pigs and humans since human and pig flesh
are pretty similar.
But the researchers also found five fragrant
compounds called esters that separated pigs
from humans.
While these esters could be the key to the
smell of human death, more research is needed.
The study only sampled certain body parts
and didn’t include the microbes that help
with decomposition that could possibly contribute
to the smell.
Besides just for funsies, the researchers
hoped that nailing down the exact molecules
behind the smell of human decay they could
“allow a more efficiently training of cadaver
dogs or portable detection devices could be
developed”.
So that could be cool, it could make it easier
for forensic investigators find evidence or
maybe it could be kind of creepy.
Most people are morbidly fascinated by the
subject of death.
It’s mysterious, terrifying, and yet comes
for us all whether we’re ready or not.
Trace recently explored the topic in depth
over on his TestTube Plus Podcast.
Check it out.
So have you ever experienced the smell of
death?
What did it smell like to you?
Tell me about it down in the comments below
and hit those like and subscribe buttons so
you don’t miss a single DNews ep